well good question i mean i can tell you
what i do want a daily basis i tell you
i mean i raise money talk to the media
we've got eight hundred thousand members
34,000 active volunteers 450 staff
people i'm kind of the couch who sits on
top of the elephant with this thing in
my hand called an anchor stand I poke
the elephant in the left ear if I wanted
to go right and maybe the elephant goes
right and maybe a thousand and I'm I'm
charged with you oh I'm quite clear on
that the elephant's a lot bigger than I
am but I think that my craft is how you
take public values and the attitudes and
temperaments of leaders in our democracy
and make those leaders do what the
public wants whether or not it's for
that reason or not I mean my job is to
take what the public wants government to
do and somehow kajol government into
doing it and that's an imperfect craft
and last couple years have been
interesting a lot of things that were
pretty predictable have gotten much less
predictable
you